this what killed me when Bruce McCain
Caitlyn that was like a national news
story later at a ridiculous level right
this is like baby seals washing up on
the beach because there's no fish left
and they're talking to this this lady
you know like so bro so you gonna go can
your Olympic back handle a deep D cup or
you're gonna go with like something a
little more perky bad way I'm just
saying I miss that guy
I miss him already should have told this
he should have given us a chance to say
goodbye on the Olympics huh I watched
him on chips I watched him on that
horrible show my wife watch where he
just walks around in the background
nobody listened to him it was just was
so sad and then I don't know I don't
know where it's just he just calls guys
Kaitlyn then you couldn't react well you
can't couldn't on any level be like oh
my go you know what the f you on any
level you couldn't say that or you
automatically homophobic yeah I didn't
hear you inner thoughts yeah I don't
know what you were doing did you shave
your beard off feel like oh my god
that's your chin wow dude came back a
woman you disposed there oh yes anyways
Kaitlyn
housing crisis
I think the bubbles traying again it's
just all right bless I got hurt
sorry they really freaked out about the
pronoun still yeah yeah you say God
bless him and they like her yeah sorry
you can see Bill show this you can see
Phil show does anybody remember laughter
at Madison Square Garden is part of the
New York Comedy Festival on November
14th for tickets to all of Bill's tour
dates visit at billboard.com I love
talking to this gentleman right here I
never know he's gonna say Bill burr
[Applause]